au sanitas le jour des rodéos c'est le
dimanche à partir de la fin de matinée
jusque dans la soirée
et ce n'est pas du gentil y ait 50
centimètres cubes avec pau silencieux
comme ce scooter élégamment entretenu
les habitants évoquent plutôt des quads
de 200 centimètres cubes des motos trial
ou des motocross type 7 centimètres
cubes
en tout cas ça en fait le bruit bon ça
tuerait un petit peu le bordel mais là
les scooters avec les pots d'échappement
en moins ou sans plaque
d'immatriculation saf le bordel ils font
des roues arrière grillent les feux
rouges
ils font peur aux gens et pas sur les
trottoirs trop c'est trop
du bruit bien sûr il en faut un peu de
bruit parce que c'est monotone mais je
pense que là c'est un peu poussé à
l'extrême un péché dangereux en plus
dans le quartier la place saint-paul
peut être un lieu de rassemblement
dominical est motorisé donc bruyant mais
ce sont les rues et allées adjacentes où
voisinent qui sont le théâtre des rodéos
moto l'allée des grands-champs martin là
les rôles en gérant ou la rue abbé
pierre sont des grandes lignes droites
propice à ces pratiques
pratique bruyante pratique dangereuse
pour les riverains aussi pratique source
récurrente d'un sentiment d'insécurité
alors pour contrer le phénomène certains
habitants évoque la manière forte
la réquisition il évolue si vous ne nous
laissez pas non
sauf que la police peut intervenir quand
le bruit dépasse les bornes ou qu'il ya
mise en danger d'autrui
si les deux roues sont vendus c'est
qu'ils peuvent être utilisés même de
manière exagérée arrêter une moto c'est
toujours un peu difficile une voiture
donc fort sur une voiture on peut soit à
travers une moto à peu prend des
trottoirs les bas côtés et en général
ils nous font faux bond forcément de
rester connaissent les cités où le ou
les rues mieux que nous donc forcément
il faut fournir près il s'arrête la moto
donc forcément aller à un endroit bien
précis s'offir neymar ou c'est si les
gens nous signale mais c'est vrai que
c'est difficile à arrêter
faire son beau sont malins sont kacou
son kéké pour les jeunes ça reste un jeu
comme ici à la batterie à saint pierre
et ça vaut tout autant au sanitas c'est
pas vraiment pour embêter les gens c'est
plutôt pour
ici il faut pas vraiment ça parce qu'ils
savent un peu que voilà qu'il ya des
gens le matin voilà qui se réveille tôt
et tout mais voilà bah prêt à ça va
jamais changer une façon c'est tout le
temps comme ça il y aura tout le temps
des gens en train de faire de la bécane
et tout et c'est pas forcément pour
embêter les gens la liberté des uns
s'arrête donc aux fenêtres et aux
oreilles des autres dans les rodéos moto
répété il y un peu de fraternité et de
concorde sociale qui est rompu